[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance across Washington wrote
Phillip Rucker of The Washington Post
Trump's allies have been buzzing about
the staffs competence as well as the
president's state of mind one GOP figure
close to the White House Museum out
whether Trump was quote in the grip of
some kind of paranoid delusion you think
what you and I have been not debating
but quantifying me for 18 months now
seems finally to have gotten through
even to the occasional Republican Donald
Trump is not well some kind of paranoid
delusion is as good a placeholder as
anything else
Trump could have a psychiatric condition
it could be physical it could be an
illness it could be substance related it
could be the long-term effects of
concussions and this is apart from the
questions of good and evil this is about
whether or not the equipment works after
President Trump accused his predecessor
in March of wiretapping him wrote the
New York Times
James B Comey the FBI director was
flabbergasted the president mr. Comey
told associates was quote outside the
realm of normal even crazy crazy
another good placeholder the point is
that only in the last couple of weeks as
much of the media political complex in
this country been willing to even hint
at what has been perfectly obvious to
many of the rest of us Donald Trump is
not well Trump has two complaints about
cabinet members Mike Allen wrote at
Axios calm either they're Tooting their
own horn 'he's too much or they're
insufficiently
effusive in praising him as a brilliant
diplomat etc Whitehouse and former
campaign aides reported Politico have
tried to make sure Trump's media diet
includes regular doses of praise and
positive stories to keep his mood up the
tactic honed by staff during the
campaign to keep him from tweeting
angrily so occasionally his staff
reportedly prints fake Time magazine
covers off the internet or articles
torpedoing each other to give to trump
this crazy stuff by the way originates
from inside Trump's White House Donald
Trump is not well as a whole the country
has appeared to be unwilling to address
this even as a possibility this is
understandable
we have gradually grown as a society to
understand the nature of mental illness
physically based or otherwise even in my
childhood this was a subject of fear and
confusion and blame and now finally we
are sympathetic but for 50 years we have
also asked our mental health
professionals not to diagnose our
presidential want to B's from afar
unfortunately this is like saying that
you cannot call it a forest fire unless
you work for the National Park Service
at the specific forest and you have
personally been singed by the fire our
refusal out of sympathy and fairness to
call some kind of paranoid delusion some
kind of paranoid delusion could destroy
this country the latest Quinnipiac poll
asked recipients to give a description
of Trump using the first word that came
into their heads not multiple-choice
just give me the word that best
describes him 46 different words were
given five times or more the leaders
were idiot incompetent liar leader
unqualified president strong businessman
ignorant egotistical [ __ ] just
missing the top 10 tied with stupid
arrogant trying excellent thoughtful
word they're trying bully business
narcissists successful disgusting great
clown dishonest racist American bigot
good money smart buffoon conman crazy
different disaster rich despicable
dictator aggressive blowhard decisive
embarrassment evil greedy in experienced
mental negotiator patriotism only three
words that even hint at psychiatric
issues quote crazy quote mental and
quote narcissist use just a combined of
23 times from a total of 527 people
Trump's aides spend 48 hours violently
insisting James Comey spiring had
nothing to do with Russia he then gives
an interview and says of course he was
thinking about Russia destroying the
argument and his aides he hinted a
secret taping system in the White House
something even Richard
Nixon hid for more than four years he
uses the phrase priming the pump about
the economy and then claims he just made
the phrase up and he asks the
interviewer do you like it even though
there is documentary evidence that prime
the pump has been used to describe
government action to energize an economy
since at least 1933 and he thinks he
just coined it last week but nobody will
call him crazy that one little quote
from the Washington Post might be a
harbinger of increased belief among his
supporters that Trump is dangerously
unstable one GOP figure close to the
White House mused privately about
whether Trump was in the grip of some
kind of paranoid delusion but they can't
admit that if you supported a candidate
and he was elected president and it
turned out you were wrong and all your
opponents were right and he really was
crazy would you admit it nevertheless it
might be leaking out over the sides in
the Quinnipiac poll On February 7th 88
percent of Republicans said they
approved Trump 75 percent said they
strongly approved Trump in the
Quinnipiac poll on May 10th 82 percent
of Republicans said they approved Trump
but only 63 percent still said they
strongly approved Trump same thing in an
NBC poll 90 percent Republican approval
On February 5th 67 percent strong
approval 88 percent Republican approve
on May 11th no change just 54 percent
strong approval to polls in which in
three months about 20% of Trump's
Republican support has sunk from strong
approval to just regular approval
maybe the Trump thing is metal health'
the chaos of his administration Russia
whatever is slowly creeping into the
awareness even of the Republicans and
they had better figure it out fast
because there is also something new and
I don't think this has been reported
anywhere else that suggests what happens
when you do not act quickly enough to
check the Trump effect this is Trump
Palace in New York City where I lived
until I sold last year
well fled is a better world than sold
I took a 10% loss to get out weeks after
I sold last July the buyer put it back
on the market and he is finally I am
told
been able to find a buyer and he has
lost 5% more in the process and this is
nothing less than the letter from the
owner of that grand penthouse the one at
the top who has been trying to sell his
place for two years according to the
real estate listings lawrence weiss has
cut his price at trump palace by 35% and
he has written to his fellow condo
owners in the building and it is
extraordinary quoting several Realtors
say that part of the problem is the
Trump name on the building just this
week a potential buyer dropped out when
their teenage daughter refused to live
in a Trump building this problem is real
and will not go away any time soon we
the owners can change the name if
two-thirds of us agree our homes are
worth more without the Trump name the
grand penthouse owner is willing to put
his money where Trump's mouth is since I
perceive a direct financial benefit from
a name change I am prepared to
underwrite the costs of a name change
disproportionately specifically I am
prepared to spend 10% of the cost of
signage changes this man is willing to
pay his neighbor's to help him take
Trump's name off their building if there
is not a metaphor in that for this
country I do not know my metaphors a 10%
Trump loss than a 5% Trump loss than a
35% Trump loss and then I'll pay you to
get rid of his name or to go back to the
Washington Post one GOP figure close to
the White House Museum our trump was in
the grip of some kind of paranoid
delusion resist peace